we live in a world with the collection
of data is happening 24 hours a day
seven days a week 365 days a year
this data is usually collected by what
we call a front desk specialist now
these are the retail clerks at your
favorite department stores the cashiers
at the grocery store is the registration
specialists at the hospital and even the
person that sold you your last movie
ticket they ask this freak questions
like may I please have your zip code or
would you like to use your savings card
today all of which gives us data however
the conversation becomes a little bit
more complex when the more difficult
questions need to be asked
let me tell you a story see what's upon
a time there was a woman named mr.
Margaret now Miss Margaret had been
afraid that specialist for almost 20
years and in all that time she has never
and I do mean ever had to ask a patient
their gender race or ethnicity because
see now Miss Margaret has the ability to
just look at you uh-huh and she can tell
if you are a boy or a girl black or
white American or non-american and in
her mind those were the only categories
so imagine that gray day when her sassy
supervisor invited her to this change
everything meeting and told her that she
would have to ask each and every last
one of her patients to self-identify she
gave her six genders eight races in over
100 ethnicities well now Miss Marta was
appalled
I mean highly offended so much so that
she marched down to that human resource
department to see if she was eligible
for an early retirement and she ended
her rent by saying that her sassy
supervisor invited her to this change
everything meeting and didn't didn't
even even bring bring food
you know you got to bring food to these
meetings anyway now that was an example
of a health care setting but of course
all businesses collect some form of data
true story
I was going to wire some money and the
customer service representative asked me
if I was born in the United States now I
hesitated to answer her question and
before she even realized why I hesitated
she begins to throw the company she
worked for under the bus she said girl I
know it's stupid but they making us ask
this question because of the way she
presented it to me I was like girl why
what a making you ask this question is
they important people but then I had to
turn on the other side of me the more
professional speaker poet side of me the
one that understood that there were
Little Miss Margaret's all over the
place people who were good people maybe
even good employees but lack the ability
to ask the questions properly and
unfortunately that made her look bad but
the worst that made the business look
even worse than how she was looking
because she had no idea who I was I mean
I literally could have been a woman who
was scheduled to do a TED talk and we
use her as an example imagine that
and unfortunately what happens is people
would decline to answer the questions
because they feel like you would use the
information to discriminate against them
all because of how you presented the
information and at that point we get bad
data and everybody know we're bad data
does bad data cost you time it costs you
money and it costs you researches
unfortunately when you have bad data it
also causes you a lot more because we
have health disparities and we have
social determinants of health and we
have the infant mortality all of which
depends on the data that we collect and
if we have bad data then we have those
issues still and we have underprivileged
populations that remain unfortunate and
underprivileged because the data that we
are using is either outdated or it's not
good at all or we don't have anything at
all now going to be amazing
if people like Miss Margaret and the
customer service representative at the
wiring place were graced to collect data
with compassionate care can I explain to
you what I mean by Grace I wrote an
acrostic poem G getting the front that
special is involved and letting them
know the are relevance of their role as
they become a accountable for the
accuracy of data while implementing C
compassionate care within all encounters
by becoming e equipped with the
education needed to inform people of why
data collection is so important now I'm
an artist and so what happens with me is
that when I create something
artistically the trainer in me is
awakened as well so what I did was I
began to develop that acrostic poem into
a for training entitled I'm graced
because I remember being the front desk
specialist and when I went to the office
of health equity to start working I was
like is that why they asked us that
asked that question it all became a
bright light to me and I realized that I
asked people and I told people about the
wrong I called them by the wrong gender
I caught him by the wrong race upon them
by the wrong ethnicity and the
environment became hostile people was
offended and I was frustrated because I
was not
I remember my computerized training and
unfortunately that training did not
prepare me to de-escalate a situation it
did not prepare me to have teachable
moments when I had questions about
asking the questions I would look at the
computer and say so what do I do when
this happened and the computer would say
nothing because the computer cannot talk
back to you so that's the importance of
having someone there who is trained to
teach you and tell you what you do in
situations like that so when I created
that I'm grace training I created it
with that experience that I had in mind
but also that conviction that I had in
mind
because I wanted the instructional
design of it to be safe space for open
dialogue for people I want to talk about
biases the unconscious ones and the
conscious ones and what we do because
now I know that when you engage people
in the Y it challenges their perspective
and it changes their attitudes now I
know that data that we have at the front
desk translate it's a research that
eliminates disparities and finds cures
now I know that teaching people
transitional change instead of shutting
them in to change it's always a better
way of implementing change see now I
know people are more likely to share
information when they are treated with
respect by knowledgeable staff members
now I know that you don't have to be a
statistician to understand the power and
the purpose of data but you do have to
treat people with respect and have
compassionate care now I know that when
you've been graced it is your
responsibility to empower somebody else
but most importantly now I know that
we're teaching human beings to
communicate with other human beings it
should be delivered by a human being
so when y'all go to work
and y'all schedule that change
everything meeting remember Miss
Margaret and don't forget the food food
[Applause]